we've got some great audience questions
I want to answer this week first one is
from Joe Joe says hey David is the
political climate for gun control
actually changing or is it more of the
same non action that we should be
expecting yeah so this is related to the
parkland Florida shooting that took
place and there's no question that we've
seen louder activism and by louder I
don't mean people yelling I just mean
like more noticeable activism around gun
safety regulations including from a lot
of younger people in the Parkland
Florida area I do not have an optimistic
view on this I believe that if we
couldn't pass just background checks
after Sandy Hook with 85 or 90% support
from the American public if absolutely
nothing changed after that horrible
Mandalay Bay shooting in Las Vegas about
six months ago
I have a really hard time believing
we're gonna see actual change with a
Republican House a Republican Senate and
a putative Lee Republican but mostly
clueless above all else president in the
Oval Office I just don't think we're
gonna see it and we've already seen the
NRA start to work I don't want to say
work its magic but do exactly what we
know it does and is expected to do to
say hey we all care about safety but
this idea you had is not a good idea and
that idea they had is not a good idea
we've already seen Trump back off of the
idea several ideas that he has had
including 21 age 21 years old minimum
age requirement for all gun purchases
Trump already seems to be backing off of
that so I am inspired that this got more
people activated but I'm pretty
skeptical that we're gonna really see
any changes I don't know if you disagree
with maybe there'll be a ban on bump
stocks the NRA doesn't really profit I
don't think too much off of those
because it's a modification right yeah
accessory and there's also I think good
constitutional standing because you're
not infringing on people's rights to
bear arms that's really it's although
I've the weapon listen it's all gray
area right once you say you shouldn't
have shoulder-mounted RPGs for can you
really say that you also were able to
you can't limit ar-15s but you can limit
bump stop
but you can't have armor-piercing
ammunition but regular in the same gun
is okay it's all great once you say that
there's any limitation it's just a
debate and it's a total gray everyone's
drawing a line somewhere now do you
think that maybe just on the background
checks we might see progress like are we
getting closer to just being able to to
maybe do that I I wish I could say I was
confident that there would be changes
but I just don't see it I really don't
probably not because right wingers have
a pretty strong due process argument I
think yeah and I know that Trump was
talking initially about worrying about
due process later which is really not
how do process were no that's the whole
point of it yeah that's the whole point
of it but I don't think we're gonna see
any progress there if not after Sandy
Hook probably not after parklandia I
want to be proven wrong right I'm not
saying this to upset people who are
activating and in fact if anything you
should get active you should get active
around this because I think that the
natural trajectory of it is we just kind
of forget about it and soon there will
be another indictment in Russia and then
Trump will have had you know some other
affair and will have deregulation of the
banking in the you know whatever there
will be important and trivial and all
sorts of other issues and we'll just
kind of forget about it until the next
mass shooting which is probably gonna be
a this week and there won't be much
coverage unless it's a big one at a
school or something well I was
pleasantly surprised that the Parkland
shooting stayed in the news for a little
while yeah best gun control I thought it
was gonna go away in like two or three
days because they're just so they're
happening so often yeah you know but
hasn't it kind of almost faded away now
I mean I still saw David hog I think
right the kids are very active and I
think that's keeping it in the news
cycle yeah but it's starting to fade it
always does